[Musica]
anche dal suono si può capire se un vino
sta bene se uscendo dalla bottiglia non
avesse fatto un suono così fluido così
libero avremmo saputo già che era un
vino difettoso è un piccolo trucco il
vino parla già molto prima del bicchiere
quelle che vedete sono alcune delle
copertine dedicate all'italia negli
ultimi 40 anni da wine spectator
di certo la rivista di settore più letta
nel mondo del vino la rivista americana
che con le sue storie recensioni ma
soprattutto con i suoi punteggi
assegnati a milioni di bottiglie negli
ultimi decenni ha spostato i gusti i
consumi di tutto il mondo per capirci
wine spectator salvino come boc sta alla
moda
giusto o sbagliato non siamo qui per
andare tanto a fondo quello che però
spero che oggi alla fine di questi
minuti insieme a possiate avere qualche
dubbio in più e qualche certezza in meno
su cosa voglia dire comprare il vino
giusto per voi e non per gli altri la
prima copertina che wise peccato dedicò
l'italia del 1978 e scegliere
un'immagine del chianti
cs rimpianti perché rappresentava quella
sorta di video di sogno che gli
americani avrebbero cristallizzato per
sempre come italian wine style la
seconda copertina che vedete molto più
recente è di aprire 2018 e siamo alla
vigilia dell'ultimo vinitaly per
sottolineare il rapporto fortissimo che
da 40 anni lega e consumi americani al
nostro vino gli americani tornano con
questa rivista sulla stessa regione per
raccontarci dopo vent'anni un modello
che già vecchio giusto o sbagliato
qui forse potremmo dire che abbiamo
perso grande occasione se in
quarant'anni non siamo stati capaci di
raccontare al mondo del vino modello
alternativo a questo
thomas matheu 6 l'edito il direttore
della rivista e alcuni mesi fa ha
rilasciato una dichiarazione sulla quale
vale la pena tornare insieme
la cosa più bella della cultura italiana
che funziona quando tutto è collegato
architettura geografia cibo e vino sono
parti dello stesso mosaico armonioso le
persone vogliono esplorare tutti insieme
ma non è l'unico a pensarla così
chef scrittrice imprenditrice
conduttrice di uno dei programmi
televisivi di maggiore successo in
america che ha tenuti incollati per anni
milioni di spettatori a 8 anni è
costretta a lasciare il suo paese di
origine cara l'istria e a trasferirsi
america con la sua famiglia ricerca di
trovare la sua dimensione da italiana e
lidia bastianich è la donna che a new
york incontra un esule istriano come lei
felice bastianich è appunto si
innamorano giovanissimi si sposano
subito avranno due figli una femmina
tania è un maschio joseph che tutti
quanti abbiamo conosciuto negli ultimi
anni come joe bastianich proprio lui
quando ascoltai lidia bastianich i dieci
anni fa a verona vista una cosa molto
importante molto semplice provo a
spiegare produttori italiani quanto
basterebbe poco per vendere più vino se
soltanto aggiungessero informazioni sul
packaging delle proprie bottiglie se
soltanto aggiungesse informazioni sulla
storia l'arte la cultura
dell'architettura dei territori in cui
li producono
l'idea strane cioè convinta che l'italia
del vino perde una grande occasione
ogni volta che non regala la propria
storia i paesi che non ne hanno una la
storia che vorrei immaginare oggi qui
con vera storia di un futuro diverso per
il nostro vino perché alle spalle
abbiamo un modello vecchio è un modello
vecchio anche fuorviante di 40 anni è un
modello generato da giornalisti guide
produttori sommelier enologi prestati
alla consulenza per non parlare negli
ultimi anni di blogger influencer in
questi 40 anni abbiamo spaccato in due
il mondo del vino da una parte le élite
e dall'altra i consumatori meno esperti
abbiamo raccontato una grande bugia che
quella per cui il vino più costosa
esempio il vino migliore abbiamo resi
been un feticcio un esercizio di tecnica
lo abbiamo chiuso in una bolla in cui
stare si stretti purché starci in pochi
abbiamo fatto in modo che in realtà
dovessimo credere sempre ai riti degli
esperti a riti spesso ridicoli
chiediamoci infatti qual è la prima cosa
che facciamo che fate quando li versano
il vino istintivamente mettiamo il naso
nel bicchiere per andarsi a cercare
quello che ci sentono gli esperti ma noi
dentro quel bicchiere
dovremo cercarsi chi siamo noi la nostra
storia e ricordi l'olfatto la nostra
memoria
quello che ci piace e non ci piace se
non facciamo questo in quel bicchiere
troveremo sempre soltanto i gusti e
ricordo degli altri
tanto più che l'olfatto è un doppio
senso perché il nostro cervello decifra
in maniera diversa lo stesso a roma
seconda che gli arrivi dalla bocca dal
naso nel suo modo retrogusto figuriamoci
se usiamo le bocche i nasi degli altri
in teoria anche al vostro naso cioè
tutto questo a patto che lo facciate
vostro a patto che lo facciamo nostro
semplicemente sovrapponendo tutte le
sensazioni olfattive del vino la nostra
memoria i nostri ricordi
davanti al vino non c'è un mondo giusto
o sbagliato cioè la vostra strada nostra
strada quella fogna di me può percorrere
non c'è un modo migliore per stare
davanti al vino io ad esempio mi occupo
di vino e del vino amo raccontare tutto
quello che c'è prima del bicchiere
perché dal bicchiere in poi uno strano
gioca come vuole
chi beve vino per il gusto di bere per
il piacere di farlo ha sempre il diritto
di trovarci se stesso
[Musica]
ratatouille un piccolo capolavoro del
cinema su questo argomento ma ora
facciamo un test insieme cerchiamo di
capire che cosa ci condiziona quando
compriamo una bottiglia di cui non
conosciamo niente di cui non abbiamo
informazioni
guardate queste cinque bottiglie di vino
rosso e pensate alla cieca quale con
previste prendetevi anche qualche
secondo per farlo solitamente quando
mostro questa immagine
la bottiglia più scelta è sempre la
solita ed è la terza e le risposte sono
la sceglierei per la bottiglia la
sceglierei perché mi piace l'etichetta
qualcuno dice anche la scelgo perché al
centro ma non c'entra nulla con il vino
questa risposta ma se io vi avessi detto
che la prima bottiglia sinistra e la
bottiglia più costosa forse voi avreste
pensato per il vino più buono lo
facciamo perché spesso cadiamo in quelle
che il neuromarketing chiama trappole
mentali e nemmeno queste quattro queste
trappole mentali sono sempre il prezzo
la marca l'etichetta la forma della
bottiglia e l'effetto bio un'altra
trappola il colore del vino
noi scegliamo e compriamo vini rossi per
sedurre e quando dico sedurre intendo un
concetto molto esteso intendo dire
conquistare un consenso portare a casa
un risultato e può valere sempre un
pranzo di lavoro che per un incontro di
coppia
i vini bianchi invece riceviamo sempre
per convivialità opere maggior
leggerezza anche le etichette del vino
perde una grande occasione bruciano
spazio perché da anni continuano a
raccontarci la solita storia dei vini
bianchi e vini rossi dei pesce delle
selvaggine o le solite banalità sempre
uguali a se stesse non sarebbe forse
meglio se ci spiegassero quale allora
forse il bicchiere adatto per degustare
meglio quel vino perché davvero la forma
del bicchiere non è un vezzo da esperti
fatta una volta un esperimento è provata
bere lo stesso vino in bicchieri diversi
voi berrete vini completamente diversi
quando viaggio mi ritaglio sempre un po
di tempo per conoscere storie persone
anche la cultura del vino che hanno in
quei paesi
qui sono in california dove ho
incontrato esperti sempre informali
sorridenti competenti senza bisogno di
indossare divise oppure il sudafrica
dove kate ha un esiste il più grande e
wine bar al mondo di vini al calice la
possibilità di acquistare bene
oltre 600 vini al calice di cui 200 sono
sudafricani
avete presente quando in italia chiedete
avete un vino al calice
la risposta di realmente un bianco rosso
vado a chiedere e le loro carte di vini
sono sempre carte veloci cartelle piene
di informazioni che fanno voglia di
ordinare vino senza paura di ordinare il
vino sbagliato la comunicazione del vino
ha bisogno di geografia chi conosce il
vino va bene in geografia è tempo di
ricominciare a valorizzare territori
minori e vini meno conosciuti di
ordinare bere vini meno conosciuti è
stata quelli che troviamo sempre sulle
carte dei vini in italia di strategia
perché uno scatto per quanto creativo
sui social non può bastare ma
soprattutto di identità perché negli
ultimi anni sui soci alle aziende hanno
un po confusi il senso del metterci la
faccia
si è completamente persa alla fiducia
nei confronti del cibo e del vino e per
ridare dignità a questo mercato serve
sforzarsi tutti chi produce e chi compra
e chi comunica soprattutto alle aziende
ora che s'era smettessero di regalare
barattare bottiglie con noi giornalisti
con i blogger e ricominciassero a darci
contenuti e sostanza
e tempo che le aziende tornino a
stupirci i vediamo gli anni di quella
che si chiama ego gastronomia perché
anche nel mondo del vin del vino le
facciano sovrastato il prodotto qualche
eccezione c'è ian d'agata uno dei più
noti critici nel mondo del vino e ha
dichiarato di aver preso ben 12 kg nello
scrivere questo libro molto bello
dedicato ai vitigni autoctoni italiani
alla faccia di quei blogger influenza
che portano continuamente foto
smaglianti sui social e mai con una foto
mentre compra una bottiglia di vino
se comprano mai una bottiglia di vino
cibo e vino hanno bisogno di cura anche
nelle parole lo aveva capito molto bene
luigi veronelli negli anni 70 nel suo
programma a tavola alle 7
li metteva insieme personaggi famosi
consumatori gente del pubblico e tutti
facevano domande senza paura di
sbagliare diceva vernelli la terra alla
terra la terra in fondo la terra
guardiamo in faccia il vino prima di
berlo se vogliamo poi ritrovarlo nel
bicchiere
e tempo di andarlo a conoscere il vino
dove si produce questo che vedete un
grappolo di amarone è tempo di tornare a
bere coerentemente con chi siamo con noi
stessi perché non dobbiamo farci
convincere più da nessuno
[Musica]
è finito
[Applauso]